[Applause]
and the spirit award for best screenplay
goes to
maggie jillian all for the last daughter
this is maggie gyllenhaal's first spirit
award win she was previously nominated
for two awards for her performances in
the film's happy endings and secretary
tonight she is also nominated for best
director and
best feature film
thank you so much thank you writers
for welcoming me into your community and
the other writers in my category we did
a panel together just the other day and
we are all in love i think and um maybe
all of us especially with janix bravo
um i don't know who's not in love with
her
um
i see
and i feel that there is a real
conscious effort being made to make
space for different perspectives and
voices and i know that i have been the
beneficiary of that
my film is in an unusual language it's
the language of the minds of women
i've been sort of afraid to say that
because my film is not just for women
it's for everyone
but
as soon as i was born i learned to speak
the language of the men who were running
the world around me it was a matter of
survival but it was also very
interesting like learning any language
and it meant that i could understand the
roots and the subtleties of a lot of
great movies
so i'm suggesting
that there can be a real pleasure in
learning a language that's not your
native one
like learning french or italian and the
the doors that it can open for you and
also
that there can be if it doesn't freak
you out a real pleasure in learning and
seeing something new
even if it doesn't look the way you
expect it to or the way that you wish it
thank you to the brilliant elena
ferrante and her translator ann
goldstein who gave me access to her work
thank you miss verante for knowing that
in your own words the effort of
adaptation requires not faithfulness but
invention and often betrayal
i think she means a sexy interactive
kind of betrayal
thank you to all my brutally honest and
loving readers netflix
you are a home for artists what a
beautiful partnership this has been
thank you
and to endeavor nagin charlie alex
kristen i was never backed into a corner
not once instead i was encouraged and
supported all the way through thank you
to my editor alfonso goncalves who is
here i think
and to my my brilliant dp helen louvard
also to my producers talia kleinhandler
and us not hendelson koran you were the
only people on my set i ever fought with
and that was be and only now and then
and that was because you were the very
closest to me my sisters and my partners
and thank you to my daughters i'm almost
done i know i thank you to my daughters
who made me a mother and helped me
understand the deepest and most
rewarding connection in the world
without whom i never would have been
able to make this movie and thank you to
my brilliant actors paul ed jack ali
jagmara dakota jesse olivia
i love all the ways that you in turn
betrayed my adaptation and gave it its
lifeblood
and one more actor who is
my favorite
my husband peter sarsgaard
who
has read almost every single draft heard
all the [ __ ] music cues
taken our kids to the dentist put them
to bed fed them breakfast held my hand
in venice when we saw the movie for the
first time but most importantly who has
taught me the beauty and the thrill of
the real thing
as opposed to the fantasy
and that was my north star making this
movie
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]